ivan chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
aurea nom étrange il habitait par les
hommes il ne dépasse jamais trois mines
il y pleut beaucoup et vous allez le
voir les montagnes semble accrocher les
nuages ou est un petit jeu tableau bleu
foncé le pacifique récifs de corail avec
linde écume où se brisent les vagues le
lagon lui bien sûr varie de couleur
suivant sa profondeur à l'horizon tahiti
et la tête et son port et nous améris on
ne peut pas toujours rester dans le
nuage c'est dommage mais c'est comme ça
il est inévitable on atterrit toujours
tahiti sommes accueillis par des
cocotiers
certainement des fleurs quelque part se
cachent encore mais nous devons nous
apparaître voilà elles sont belles elles
sortent sur mon entraînement plages de
sable fin
enfin rien de bien original pour les
îles tropicales mais ce qui est beaucoup
plus original c'est la population il est
nécessaire de vraiment bien la connaître
tahiti n'est pas une ville n'est pas un
village taille qui est une espèce de
club c'est vraiment une sorte de club
dont on a intérêt à connaître le mans
à tahiti on cultive le coprin et ce
d'une façon assez amusant le vent
souffle à tahiti comme partout
d'ailleurs là il est vraiment l'allié
des tahitiens quand il souffre il fait
tomber les noix de coprah alors le tai
chi à rentrer se cache attend que le
vent ait fait son travail
ensuite il sort et ils ramassent les
doigts de coprah il aura ensuite bien
sûr du travail à faire mais le plus
difficile la récolte elle se fait tout
seul là bas il y a une chose qui est
absolument recommandé si vous allez à
tahiti
le gars est jamais votre voiture sous un
cocotier ou alors votre carrosserie sera
absolument beauce où les enfants
s'amusent de travail en même temps ce
qui est très efficace et utile
voici une vérité première si une noire
est sur la terre humide comme elle est
logique cette noix n'y elle germe sa
chair se décompose en matière spongieuse
qui alimente le germe et ainsi de suite
mais elle est utilisée bien entendu pour
d'autres usages
voyez vous cette poule elle servira à
faire des gâteaux
il suffit de sortir cette pulpe de
l'école c'est un travail qui semble
assez pénible vous regardez le coin
voilà d'un peu plus près la même chose
pour vous voyez mieux
ne manquons pas de gâteau aux noix de
coco j'ai l'impression
voilà comment il s'y prend et cette
opération c'est au fond à vous montrer
des choses a premièrement comment se
dégage la noix et deuxièmement ce que
l'on fait de ce qu'il vient de rejeter
ça ce sera le gâteau c'est la poudre de
noix de coco est ce qu il a rejeté tout
à l'heure sera brûlé et fera de
l'engrais vous allez le voir du reste de
l'eau la noix de coco que l'on appelle
communément du let us et une erreur du
rail soyaux ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure on brûle et ça fera de l'engrais
je vous disais que l'eau de la noix de
coco est tellement pur on peut la
prendre pour faire une intraveineuse
sans faire bouillir cette eau et puis
ensuite on retourne foyer et on est très
très fiers d'admirer son fils ou sa
fille ici comme partout tailleurs qui
jouent dans l'eau qui s'amusent et les
animaux familiers là bas même s'il son
cochon doivent être propres
alors on les lave
oui
voyez ici il n'y a pas du tout le
grosses vagues et cela provient du fait
que beaucoup plus loin à 3 ou 4000 m les
vagues se sont brisés sur des récifs et
la pirogue et en haïtien ce que la
voiture et aux parisiens ou autre homme
détendu
le ciel est souvent couvert le cocotier
à beaucoup d'autres utilisations
ici on est en train de presser ses
palmes ont les traits ce sont les
mouiller dans l'eau de mer
on les laisse sécher sous la forme des
lattes et ses lacs servent à la
construction
j'en doute y est probablement
et maintenant voici le port de papeete
c'est un très joyeux endroit vous voici
en photos emma pavillon français et là
c'est un petit peu internationale je
disais donc que papeete et un port fort
joyeux où il y a des fêtes s'est fait du
rab à 15 jours
on y trouve à peu près tout ce qu'on
peut souhaiter dans une fête foraine
manèges les tirs des concours organi
manque même la grande roue et voici mon
four un concours de cause de pirogues
ces cours se tirent toujours la
population l'ensemble de ces troisièmes
gens au fond royaume ce sont des
baleinières elles servent à franchir les
récifs ses baleiniers allaient receipt
des îles de l'est elles appartiennent au
fond à l'histoire d' aventure du pastis
gracieuse comme tous et qui rendent
profil du vent comme le tahitien et noix
de coco mais pour d'autres sports depuis
toujours un concours toujours une eau de
coco vous voyez planté au sommet se
détend cette fois c'est un concours de
sagaie à chaque tahitien on donne 10
aguets ce qui lui permet beaucoup de
coups apparentes au moins 10
ouali
à hauteur de noix de coco et a dit m et
le tir je fais à 40 mètres de là
ils sont pas très bien nourris à tahiti
où il ya beaucoup d'appelés peu d'élus
cela comme partout ailleurs
plus tard
on
il
maintenant les danses il n'y a pas de
vue de tahiti tendance nîmes pas que
région où les femmes je sois aussi
gracieuse sans faillir l'impasse il y en
a bien sûr mais celles ci sont
particulièrement gracieux et on pense
toujours que ce que l'on voit à présent
c'est pourquoi je disais il n'ya pas du
pays les femmes sont plus gracieuse mais
celles ci sont ford refuse cette danse
est pas toi
et oui tout a une fin et six fois par an
on quitte pas fait pour la france il est
vrai qu on le fait aussi dans le sens
inverse on peut quitter la france pour
pater c'est toujours un événement ce
départ où cette arrivée ils attirent la
foule
et même ceux qui n'ont pas droit au
voyage qui n'ont pas envie qu'ils ne
peuvent pas faire ce voyage ont accès
aux bateaux là bas on couvre les gens de
colliers de fleurs vous avez vu même un
gendarme après tout pourquoi pas un
gendarme je chante fort souvent des
hommes charmants le gendarme beaucoup de
fleurs quelques larmes et au fond cela
veut simplement dire revenait très vite
s'il vous plaît
ivan chagnaud vous a proposé royal sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de solange péters
montage michel la touche crypte lucette
andreï son annick v10 illustrations
sonores
dominick péladeau